six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's see who else wants to
chat today let's try our next caller
from seven eight zero go ahead caller
from seven eight zero hi my name is Tom
I'm just wondering why I've heard both
you and Kyle kolinsky call dr. Jordan
Peterson a religious nut huh and I'm
just wondering why the use of AD
homonyms and I know I'm going to use a
appeal to authority fallacy when I say
he's highly educated he has 30 years of
experience in human identity is it
because he doesn't fit into the same
leftist narrative or is it because he
uses religious undertones in his
philosophy that you would that I see a
lot of this being called religious nut
and then dismissing his arguments based
on that I have never dismissed a
particular argument of his on the basis
of his being a quote religious nut but
so like for example right when he said
during a debate with Matt Dillahunty
that even atheists who think they don't
believe in God actually do deep down is
that an argument to you that seems like
a verifiable argument in the realm of
science or does that seem like a
completely undefeatable argument that is
really of no particular use that we
would really only hear from someone
who's who's a religious individual you
tell me well I'm not a religious
individual myself I just find I find the
both on the left and especially on the
right with the far right individuals
using that homonyms to attack people I
just find that using religion or other
means to say I don't know perhaps this
argument is completely unreasonable but
hold on let's let's instead of making it
this so religious nut is not I mean I
guess it isn't ad hominem in a sense but
really what we're talking about here is
someone whose ideas is everything okay
there yeah
okay um it sounded like you were under
attack for a second there listen my
point about Jordan Peterson is that the
the idea is that he is welcomed as this
sort of hyper empiricists who is always
working within the realms of what's
demonstrated by data and so on and so
forth and then he makes the argument
that even atheists actually are
religious so that we can't really say
you can have a moral moral compass
without religion because even those who
think they're not religious actually are
religious what are you gonna do with
that right how is that really a serious
argument so that that's a comment about
a small argument you know yeah that's
the problem with him he takes a lot of
cultural and religious norms and under
penances philosophy philosophy based on
that and I guess when talking to someone
like Matt OMB of course it would come
off as super religious versus ATS well
but aside from about it aside from super
religious is the argument that there
aren't really atheists because even if
they don't know it they actually believe
in God is that an argument that is is a
useful argument in the sense that we
could we can even measure that because
the idea is even the atheists don't know
that they're religious like that just it
seems it seems like whew to me it
doesn't seem useful in any way yeah true
enough I'll have to agree with you on
that point I realize maybe I interview
with Matt doe on t where he actually
said that that's completely unreasonable
all right very well hey listen we ended
up agreeing which is uh which is a
really really great thing let's take a
quick break if you're holding on we are
taking more calls after the break so
please don't hang up because we will get
to you